foreign
this call to prayer is a call to action
to Muslims faith is a verb more than
just reading it's putting principles
into practice
he tests different people on different
days tomorrow it could be us that is
going through a flood famine drought
hunger difficulty we don't want that to
be us and should that be us we are going
to find rest in the fact that there are
our brothers and sisters across the
globe who are going to help us suffering
in Pakistan Brothers the floods may have
happened four thousand miles away in
Pakistan that the scale of suffering is
felt strongly among Britain's Muslims
charity is a pillar of the faith
if you're planting good seeds then
hopefully you'll be able to to sow some
good commas in in the future some of
them don't have food and they're
suffering and a lot of people have so I
think we should help them and it will be
very kind too parents are suffering as
well because what their children need to
feed us
despite the cost of living up to 6 000
pounds was raised in one hour
small change to many making a big
difference
the funds rings from today's collection
is going to go on to help provide
emergency aid to those that are
vulnerable at the moment from Food Packs
to emergency hygiene kits to even
putting people into a shelter as well
[Music]
back at the congregation empty your
wallets but prayers heavy with hope for
the people of Pakistan Saba chowdry Sky
News Finsbury Park